if I work out in the morning I'm going
on a podcast but if I don't work out I
suck on a podcast and I'm just like huh
yeah yeah that's cool no I I I'm
my favorite is I used to do this a lot I
haven't done it in a while is
uh full busy day nap at home box of wine
on the treadmill
and do that until like midnight watching
TV box of wine box of wine on a
treadmill it's the best height wait how
are you sipping it Jake you have a glass
but you have a box the box fits on the
corner on the treadmill so you just got
a little spigot yeah and you sit there
and just put on like Guys Grocery Games
or like just something it's like a you
walking or are you running I walk I walk
in like a three five so what will happen
is if you started a three start of three
casual walk 20 minutes to get a mile in
and then you and you're gonna feel loose
get up to a three five
you can do seven miles on these things
and just and just and you're just
enjoying your night and specially like
my wife back in the day when we lived in
our old house my wife would come into
the man cave and she's sitting on the
couch and we watch TV together yeah and
like watch Game of Thrones and use like
for an hour and you just get on the
treadmill and do it oh man I I loved I
haven't done that as much lately because
that was the [__] you can lose
yourself you can forget yourself you
forget you're on a treadmill and you
just are like walking and you're
sweating and you're and you're having
wine and then at certain points you're
like
like uh you like you you start jogging
especially like are we watching uh not
All Quiet on the rest in front what's
the one where they've gotta they've got
to get the message to the front line
I would run like I was in World War II
yeah a run when they would run and it
was [__] awesome and I would be like
because they were doing drinks they'd be
like take a drink you got to run up
there and be like okay
yeah I'm really into I'm really into
History Podcast right now like I've been
in them for a while 20th century or
everything everything everything I
listened to
um
uh
was it Marcus Aurelius and Cleopatra
today uh in the middle of the podcasts
are like you know just so you know
Cleopatra wasn't as hot as everyone says
I was like why are you saying that yeah
tell me she's a six you look like Snooki
yeah like why let me let me dream that
she looks like Kim Kardashian yeah and
then I listened to that one today I
listened to World War II a lot oh a lot
of books on World War II a lot of uh
podcasts about it what's your favorite
theater the Pacific or or european
uh no European Pacific well because my
family's so much of it has died in that
theater so to this person so much of it
I hate this song cliche like I'm Arnold
Schwarzenegger in an 80s movie but it's
personal well you know what I find funny
about that yeah is Lenin
it was Lenin right uh John Lennon no no
no one was it Lenin was World War II
right or was it Stalin Stalin Stalin
Stalin thought him and Hitler would be
friends yeah I think that's so cute that
he was like we're gonna be buddies yeah
like we're boys yeah and then Hitler's
like oh [__] you I'm Hitler bro this is
what I do well at first he was like
[__] yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah we'll
be friends yeah yeah sure sure and then
call me call me better yet I'll show up
in Winter how's that sound yeah that uh
that uh I find that I find all of that
so fascinating when I was a kid I had a
hard time understanding how because we
were always at war with Russia when I
was a kid and I had a hard time
understanding how we could be on the
same team as Russia in World War II
and I was like wait how did that turn
South and then you just listen to
podcasts yeah I'm that
all of that all of that like
all of the World War II I got really
into the the Pacific [__] for a while
but I'm really deep in the
in
in the whole we we went to Normandy from
the The Cliffs of Dover and to think so
that's the [__] beach
that's the [__] beach oh [__] this is
cold as [__] these dudes jumped in ice
cold water yeah and this isn't like a
cool beach like this is
and it's just so insane
to and then to see like the the it's
pretty intense I don't know why I got
into history late in life I wasn't I was
kind of into it but I'm really into it
now and I love just learning a little
something about
you know today was I listened to like
the noise or has a great history stuff
it's like History For Dummies I think
like I get to I can't listen to the
really smart stuff starts losing me too
many names and I'm gone yeah well Dan
Carlin is always the best
your podcast with Dan Carlin yeah was so
[__] good he is
he is I mean I only know about Martin
Luther because of Dan Carlin I only know
like I would have I made a joke about
some Lutheran the other day
and everyone laughed and I was like did
you guys listen to the same podcast I
did because I just am quoting Dan Carlin
uh that his podcast I mean we all quoted
the same [__] about uh Genghis Khan
about how he could shoot a dove off a
horseback but we knew that all four
hoofs had to be off the ground at the
same time they shot they would sometimes
take their meat and stick it under their
Saddles and that I mean Dan Carlin is he
is the [__] yeah God those were
man discovering podcasts was the coolest
time of my life and the interesting
thing about him is is audio
and so this is the voice
so for me I mean everybody has a story
with a prostitute in a motel
Dan Carlin was my prostitute in the most
I invited him to a motel I don't even
remember in the middle of nowhere he
shows up with that voice
and the rest the rest is history so good
things they will never know what
happened oh boy did he like no I'm just
kidding I'm I'm really running with it
but yes we did we got along with it I
mean he's an incredibly kind and
thoughtful person constantly
self-critical thinking he's not good
enough he just works on those episodes
forever forever and he just thinks that
there's these uh just like with Goggins
there's these
other historians that I think like weigh
on him like they're going to judge him
or something like this in his mind I
talked about I talked to it with him but
Daniel Battalion and I guess
his thing is he I get I guess his his
hang up is Collins is he's not a he he's
not like this like he doesn't feel like
he's a real historian yeah but he is
yeah I mean it's the way he shares the
story the queen of history teacher in
seventh grade who's a con artist and he
came and taught her seventh grade and it
was the whole con artist all he taught
us about was barnstorming barnstorming
and the JFK assassination I walked away
having such an appreciation for
barnstorming a very small blip on
Americana but I know a lot about
barnstorming because of this guy and he
because he was passionate about
barnstorming it was a fun seventh grade
history class I'll ever take in my
entire life